yeah not yet don't don't don't let the
cat out of the bag quite
yet you guys know what I'm talking about
what's your name Benjamin Franklin no it
was my last name is Lawson so it was
Osama Ben Lawson Osama Ben Lawson is
fing crazy Jillian rate yourself as a
dancer 1 through 10 I'm going to give
myself an eight yeah Jillian why did
your friend look so surprised when you
said
that she was like damn give me one word
to describe your dance style um
[Music]
sultry I like how you nonchalant
sultry you know sultry you're going to
have a heart on don't worry about it
what's the name of your best dance move
I was going to say sprinkler wa do you
see what Osama Ben Lawson's got under
that
rope why do you think he calls himself
the
sprinkler fluid
twerk
[Music]
blue with twk yet not yet don't
don't don't let the cat out of the bag
quite
yet you guys know what I'm talking
about tell me what's the name of your
best dance move the Lotus Flower Bomb I
don't
[Applause]
know that sounds like a professional
wrestling move I'm not going to lie yeah
dude when you do it I hope you go ooh
yeah the lotus flower
bom Osama Ben Lawson you're up first
everybody you
are my
fire the
one
[Music]
desire when I
say I want it that
way
yeah did he just button pop his
shirt I'm keep I'm keeping just this
button I'm putting it I'm putting it in
my butthole
later dare I say that Osama Ben Lawson
killed the
Lotus you take it easy he was like he
was like fluid JK fluid J FL T he
couldn't get that out of hising mouth
fast enough it was a that was a FL T
tell that was
talk you
are my
fire the
one
desire when I
say I want it that
way
yeah I think the very first fluid twerk
we've seen on this yeah
dude you wer watching yeah yeah yeah
yeah what' you say you had already
[Music]
come you
are my
fire the
one
desire
believe when I
say I Want It That Way
W that was amazing hey yo I did not see
that
coming Dam
whoa it was so elegant and then she was
like
boom yeah I love that she was she was
like a swan and then she was like let's
eat
this
what we will do here is we're going to
we're going to pick a winner but here's
what else I do man whenever I go to a a
new city I like to buy a new guitar and
then the last show of the weekend I give
the guitar away and
so all right everybody you guys pick the
winner okay okay
Renee
all right all
right I'm sorry one
time Osama Ben
[Applause]
[Music]
lasson wow wow wow wow wow wow wow now
listen dude your vote doesn't count
twice on this one all right you can't
raise two hands one so so you definitely
can't raise two hands when one's on your
neck that's for
[Laughter]
sure all right so listen one time
everybody and by the way all three of
them deserve such a huge round of
applause for being up here
[Applause]
one time everybody for Jillian let her
he one time for
[Applause]
[Music]
Jillian ladies and gentlemen I think we
have picked a winner the winner for
tonight and who was your server
[Music]
Ben Lee you are the proud winner of
$100
yeah you win
$100 and my man this this guitar is
yours come up here yeah yeah
yeah I gave you enough sh you should be
able to take this guitar home with you
say you were on his ass yeah dude there
you go dude thank you so much for coming
out tonight everybody